bonjour à tous je m'appelle j'y vais
assez riche et réalisateur et je suis là
pour vous parler de mon prochain projet
avec faire on est parti sur une idée
toute simple on s'est dit on part en
vacances où on fait un film on s'est dit
qu'on allait faire un film night faire
c'est un long métrage de cinéma
ambitieux un thriller d'action
psychologique avec des gros enjeux de la
cascade des techniciens exceptionnel et
un grand metteur en scène qui nous a
suivis et rejoint sur le projet
aujourd'hui ce qu'on recherche c'est la
liberté aujourd'hui secours cherchent
c'est de pouvoir faire le film qu'on a
envie sans demander la permission aux
financiers sorte donné la permission à
ce qui de toute façon mettre des plombes
à répondre nous ce qu'on veut c'est
faire le fil tout de suite on a le temps
on veut tourner maintenant on a besoin
de vous pour concrétiser sa et le faire
dans de bonnes conditions
donc l'idée maintenant c'est de faire
autrement c'est de proposer nouvelle
manière de faire de produire à nous
trois entre les le réalisateur avec deux
producteurs on a dû faire 500 600 films
publicitaires
notre expertise nous permet de mettre en
place des systèmes de production
efficace pertinent et c'est ce qu'on a
envie de faire aujourd'hui on n'a pas
envie de déposer un dossier sur un
bureau et puis attendre dans deux ans
qu'on me dise oui tu peux où tu peux pas
aujourd'hui on tourne on tourne
mais on peut pas tourner sans vous de
petits connards qui sortent d'une forêt
parisé mais la rose et décide de rentrer
chez eux à 15km de pareils ils prennent
le taxi
jusque là tout va bien il faut arriver
sur place ils vont faire un taxi basket
on va décider de ne pas payer la course
c'est juste pas le bon chauffeur a kiffé
le faire ça le driver qui ne va pas les
lâcher de toute la nuit il va leur faire
payer la bourse
autrement
différemment physiquement
psychologiquement ils vont s'offrir un
film de tension c'est un film de
suspense c'est un film viscéral
on a voulu rendre hommage et se
rapprocher du sujet du traitement très
très simple de duel de spielberg
décès de faire un film faisable dans
notre économie mais sans jamais perdre
de vue la qualité on va faire un film
sans concession
on va faire un film qui me ressemble le
film j'ai presque envie de vous dire que
ce sera mon vrai premier film julien ces
trois longs métrages 500 publicité des
collaborations avec des acteurs
internationaux comme robbie williams ou
bien d'autres il a accepté de nous
rejoindre sur le projet est de porter
avec nous cette aventure un peu folle
qui est naïve faire grâce à mon
expérience dans le métier
trois longs métrages quatre téléfilms
quelques clips vidéo et quelques
dizaines de courts métrages produits
les gens me font confiance et dès qu'on
a lancé l'idée de ce projet tous ont
répondu présent merci à eux
on a une équipe qui est qui traite à
tourner maintenant il nous manque votre
soutien pour concrétiser ça on a besoin
de vous pour boucler le budget et
réussir à tourner ton inhabituel parce
que je trouve ça génial aujourd'hui que
le public puis choisir quel film il a
envie de voir quel film il a envie de dd
à au développement ça va être un film de
genre ça va être un film différent
on a le potentiel en france il faut
qu'on voie il faut qu'on s'en aperçoive
et là c'est l'occasion ou jamais de
médecins en évidence voilà c'est ça qui
m'a séduit à vos trousses aujourd'hui
vous avez la possibilité de nous offrir
cette liberté artistique de faire le fou
et on adore règles vont nous accompagner
jusqu'au bout et on vous promet de faire
le meilleur film possible
on a besoin de vous donc allez-y cliquer
à vous faire du david fincher avec du
budget de godard alors ça c'est du
challenge en nous aidant à le produire
on va lancer un message fort on va faire
les films qu'on a envie de voir au
cinéma les jeux qu'on a envie de
défendre personnellement ça me manque
aujourd'hui on a besoin de vous pour
nous aider à produire ce film c'est
grâce à vous qu'on va donner une
nouvelle vie au cinéma indépendant j'ai
besoin de vous maintenant